passion follow my passion passion follow
your passion recognize your passion
passion passion hello believe nation
today we're gonna look at how you can
follow your passion and as always if
someone says something really meaningful
to you please leave in the comments
below and put quotes around it so other
people can be inspired as well enjoy
[Music]
what are your thoughts and what's your
approach on finding and building upon
passions passion is not an actionable
word it's correct you know that those
who do the things that they're
passionate about do better but it's not
helpful advice and so the question is
where does passion come from passion is
a result passion is an energy
passion is the feeling you have when
you're engaged in something that you
love passion is the feeling you have
that you would probably do this for free
you know and you can't believe somebody
pays you to do it you know and I think
we mistake that passion is something we
do in our private lives but it shouldn't
be done you know in our careers for
example and I'm a firm believer that you
are who you are and anybody who says I'm
different at home than I am at work and
one of those two places you're lying and
the goal is to make everything you do in
home and it works something that you
have excitement to do so how do you find
the things that you're excited to do
well it's actually easier than you think
what are the things that you love to do
what are the things that you would do
for free you know how can you recreate
that feeling and and be pay for it so
what are the things that I do on the
weekend right I love I'm very involved
in the art world I love to go to museums
and galleries but I love to go see dance
and performances because I want to see
how others are interpreting the world so
that inspires me new ideas new thoughts
new ways of looking at the world are
things that interest me privately and I
seek it out and pay money for it right
so does that mean I have to have a
career in the arts no it means I have to
have a career where new ideas are
explored where people are experimenting
and trying things out and I have to
explore new ideas and try things out and
I'm just as excited to go to work
everyday as I am just you know go do
something on a Saturday night and so the
idea of finding your passion is
ironically simple because you should be
doing stuff that you enjoy sometimes
what is the stuff that you enjoy and
then what is the stuff that you love who
the people that you love and what are
that's what they all have in common
everybody around me their parents were
lawyers or investment bankers or
entrepreneurs or they were all laying
involved in business and that actually
didn't seem very much fun to me growing
up so I thought that being an adult's
kind of a drag I actually was pretty
depressed when I graduated from college
I was literally depressed for like six
months I woke up at one o'clock in the
afternoon and laid on a couch I looked
up at the ceiling just do what am I
going to do
and so with no inspiration I just
decided you know what
the only thing I can think of to do
right now that's gonna make me happy is
if I go surfing as I planned a
five-month trip around Australia
Indonesia living out of a backpack in a
van at the time if I didn't follow my
passion for surfing I would have never
had the idea for GoPro how do you choose
what's interesting to you I mean how do
you decide something I have to feel
passionate about I mean it it people
don't know this but to make a good film
has to be one of the hardest things
known to humankind to make I mean
there's so many factors that go into
making a good film and like filmmakers
who are passionate about this we kill
ourselves to do this so you spend a year
two years in the Malcolm X I took two
years that's that's time out of your
life and you have to have that passion
for the subject matter for this but
whatever it is it makes you want to go
ahead and press the fear the difference
between people who are successful or not
or though those who are successful seem
to know from age of 7 or 8 maybe older
you know they're very in tune with what
they love they I compared to a voice
inside their head not literally a voice
but it's something exciting you really
are drawn to this subject and they hear
it throughout their lives that for me it
was it was writing and books since I was
a kid and you know at any time I
deviated from that love and went into
something else I just was so unhappy I
knew that I wasn't doing the right thing
and so it's just like this voice that
keeps drawing me back to what you really
really love why did comedy kind of
become your thing do you think or did
comedy kind of pick you well that's
that's a nice way of putting it
that's a nice way of putting it I would
say that the you know I I can't under
emphasize how important
comedy has been to my life and how
important certain you know opportunities
that came along to my life and they all
many of them seem sort of acts
for instance like second city I never
thought of mines I didn't think I was
gonna be a comedian I had a sort of
secret desire as a high schooler to be a
comedian I didn't know that meant you
know I didn't know what I just really
liked being funny I'm from one of eleven
kids and we're a funny family and being
funny was important like the the king of
the room was whoever was funniest you
know and I remember as a child you know
I seen comedy helping my man family had
a tragedy when I was younger my father
and two of my brothers died and I
remember my sister making another one of
my sisters laughed so hard on the way on
the the car away from the cemetery one
of my sisters made the other sister
laugh so hard that she fell on the floor
of the limo one of the big floors like
with a rumble seat facing each other and
she fell on the floor laughing and I
remember thinking I want to do that and
I don't know whether it was specifically
within the context of dealing with
tragedy because I don't think I was
always on ten and but I remember
specifically thinking I want that I'd
love to have been able to do that right
now
and then I fell asleep every night for
years listening to Bill Cosby
wonderfulness very funny fellow
David Frye Richard Nixon to fantasy
George Carlin class clown let's get
small wild and crazy guy and I would
just back when you could stack albums so
many stacks how many of them the top one
kind of blades roll as it went around
and and then I went to college to be an
actor but an actor actor I were black
and I had a beard and you know I was
like let me share my misery with you
you know poet slash jerk kind of actor
and then I accidentally met some people
from second city and and took some
classes there and got invited to
audition and accidentally just over the
happy accident fell in with some great
people and I still would like quit for
second city four times in order to go do
straight black box
avant-garde kind of theater in Chicago
which is that's what I was gonna be I
was gonna live in a studio apartment
with no furniture and a futon on the
floor that I stuffed myself with a yak
fur
just drained be single and with the
beard and you know sandals and a dashiki
and I was gonna you know drink from a
samovar that was constantly bubbling in
the background and and but then one day
I was backstage I kept on returning to
doing comedy and I was backstage one one
night this is really the thing that made
the decision for me I was backstage with
a guy named Dave Rose outski who does
does a what's it called a web there's
the most blonde was over audio it does a
podcast as a podcast yeah what do you
kids do your podcasts it's great guy
we're backstage somebody was on stage
and they were supposed to do a very
simple blackout and a blackout is a very
short it's got one joke and then the
lights go out this is second city it's a
pace keeper for the show she goes out
there and the blackout is this she goes
you know we're supposed to say I like to
a song for you now welcome to the you
know the no exit cafe like do with some
feet right now a song for the whales and
then she did to make think of you tune
up your guitar for a long time this is a
song for the whales and then you go very
simple you do whistling clicks and
everything it's fine not a big not a
great laughs but it had works every time
she goes out there to do it I like you I
like do a song for you right now like
two thumb fear right now she just goes
into her whistling on her clicking and
we're backstage waiting to go on for the
next scene me and Dave and we said was
not getting any laughs what's this is
foolproof
no laughs at all what's going on
something's wrong and then she goes oh I
forgot it's song for whales
[Music]
and we burst into laughter backstage and
we threw our arms around each other in
the agony of her failure and we're just
laughing we fell like I like it like a
collapsing teepee we just fell to the
ground and Dave's feet went out on to
stage like this as we held each other
like lovers the most intimate joyful
experience at her pain that we all knew
and she could hear it happen in order to
see our feet and she started laughing at
how wonderfully she had just failed and
and I thought at that moment this is
what I want if if failure of this scale
can cause this much joy for anyone then
this is the healthiest thing that I
could do with the rest of my life and I
will do nothing else and I have never
looked back from that moment the I often
say to people who talk to me about
Shakespeare who never are not actors or
directors I've never played it or done
it the actor learns Shakespeare in
another way because he learns it having
to do it having to spend months with it
so he approaches it in that way and
understands it in that way and the
familiarity with the words and the
phrases and what the content is what
it's saying becomes a part of you and
the revelations keep coming long after
you closed in a play you know you you
learn things and you hear things in a
way that you could never if you saw the
play or if you read the play no that's
why actors in a way of lucky that they
get an opportunity to that's why some of
the great ones that that had the
repertoires of plays that so wanted to
do it because it had so much in it it's
almost I can come close to say say you
were cello you played the cello or
something and you were playing Bach on
the cello
I mean Wow imagine that you know
so so that that that manifestation of
spirit which comes out of it changes you
it lifts your life that does it gives
you so much and once that that appealed
to me when I was very young I really I
was a very young guy when I started to
do Strindberg and and things like that
was very affected by that because I
thought here it is with this material
it's like playing the cello because I
can kind of just express things in
myself and it made me sort of
universally it gave me a more universal
sense of things in myself because I was
doing things that happen to use years
ago II I was out of the South Bronx I
was out of the life I come from into
another world that was giving me all
this stuff it was a gift and I knew from
that point on age 21 I knew at that
point I had been acting since I was this
big
but at that point I thought this is what
I do with my life and nothing matter
being famous
being rich nothing only doing this now
at 21 that's easy to say you know it's
just you and pizza but it is true that
they did a panini follow your passion
and and not chase money and you'll hear
people say that and it doesn't make
sense because they think like it sounds
like such a like abstract thing like
follow your passion you know it's like
this like all positive thinking mantra
or whatever but the reality is is that
business is really really really really
hard and if you're in business and
you're doing it just for the money and
you're not doing it because you really
care what's going to happen is is when
things get tough it's going to be easy
for you to quit because the money is not
enough reward you know it has to come
down to doing something that you're
passionate about something that you love
something that you that you want to get
up and do every day because that way
when you're not making money and the
money's not there you still do it anyway
and you get better anyway so it makes it
easier for you to continue to get better
and improve which is what's required for
you ultimately reach the goal so I
really think that following a passion is
a requirement of being successful
for the simple fact that it makes it
almost impossible to quit you know so
try to figure out what it is you're
passionate about what it is that you
enjoy and and you're in naturally become
better you're going to naturally endure
the times of when it's hard because you
love it thank you for inviting me to
celebrate with you today Tisch graduates
you made it and
[Music]
[Applause]
think about that the graduates from the
College of Nursing they all have jobs
the graduates from the College of
Dentistry fully employed the Leonard and
Stern School of Business graduates
they're covered the School of Medicine
graduates each one will get a job the
proud graduates of the NY School of Law
they're covered and if they're not who
cares they're lawyers the English majors
are not a factor
they'll be home writing their novels
teachers there all be working three jobs
lousy pay yeah but still working the
graduates in accounting they all have
jobs where does that leave you envious
of those accountants I doubt it
they had a choice maybe they were
passionate about accounting but I think
it's more likely that they used reason
and logic and common sense to reach for
a career that could give them the
expectation of success and stability
reason logic common sense at the Tisch
School of Arts are you kidding me but
you didn't have that choice did you you
discovered a talent developed an
ambition and recognized your passion
when you feel that you can't fight it
you just go with it
when it comes to the arts passion should
always trump common sense you want just
following dreams you're reaching for
your destiny you're a dancer a singer a
choreographer and musician a filmmaker a
writer a photographer a director a
producer and actor an artist yeah yeah
the good news is that that's not a bad
place to start now that you've made your
choice or rather succumb to it your path
is clear not easy but clear you have to
keep working it's that simple the power
for me to be successful was not in the
teachers it was not in the educational
system it was not in my culture it was
not in my society it was within me and I
began to think God if you are a good god
why am i poor if you are a great god why
are these people better than me if you
make me in your image why are they
special and I'm a monkey and that night
no thunder no lightning no earthquakes
nothing I just heard a voice in my mind
and the voice said I ask you to believe
me
and you will be saved not them and that
night I made a commitment to believe
what God said 13 years ago it's okay I
believe that I have the power to
experience far beyond all I can ever ask
think or imagine 13 years old and that's
when my pursuit of God began when was it
that you realize you wanted to become a
preacher you know I didn't want to
become a preacher matter of fact today
is still consider myself a preacher I
think it drove me to have a passion to
help everybody who's been oppressed my
passion is to make sure that no one
should live under what I experienced I
never desired to be a minister I desired
to help people
this was Schrader's passion in a way and
then somehow we picked up on it and was
danira myself and all felt as powerfully
just attached to it as as shredded did a
New York New York came out came came
from something that I wanted to an
explore genre and I started a fool
around mixing genre with what you might
call him prophet Ori style like the
Cassavetes or even Kazan to a certain
extent and blending the two and that was
a that was a failure at the box office
and in Hollywood and it sort of set me
off on a road feeling I never knew if
I'd have the passion again to do
something from myself we had to make a
movie again make a movie ever make a
movie again that came for me because I
realized that I just couldn't go to work
meaning go to work like okay here's the
script go there Monday morning be there
at 5:30 and tell this person and the
person getting to that act will have his
own ideas or her own ideas and you don't
agree with them but you're gonna have to
go to I don't know if I could do that I
don't know if I the energy to do it or
really wanted to do it and so a De Niro
during the period of making New York New
York and little earlier actually when I
was doing Alice does liver anymore he
give me the book of raging bullet he
wanted to make this and by that point in
time I wasn't it seemed to be more
generated from him and as I said sports
films I didn't get but it's not a sports
film I didn't realize that until I've
gone through my own two or three years
of soul-searching and
having some difficult times and finally
winding up in the hospital and I found
that ultimately when I was in the
hospital it was kind of like a kind of a
strange miracle in a way I couldn't I
couldn't go any I couldn't reach any
further down I was in bottom and when he
came to see me and he just wanted really
to make that film he wanted me to get
out of that hospital bed too but he
wanted me to make me buddy want to make
the film come on you could do this you'd
be so greedy to what are you doing with
your life look at you you know you know
come on please you could really do it I
said I said okay it suddenly hit me I
think I understood what it was and
somehow through him we had this
extraordinary collaboration mostly in a
sense of very very collaborative and
almost to the point where we didn't
necessarily have to talk that we kind of
felt similar ways about my life and
about people and and the the process the
artistic process and just living trying
to live being and all these different
emotions we felt we kind of shared and
so I thought that was the film thank you
guys so much for watching I'd love to
know what clip resonated the most with
you what did you learn from this video
that you're gonna apply to your life or
your business please leave it in the
comments below I'm gonna join in
discussion I also want to give a quick
shout out to Jay Wong Jay thank you so
much for picking up ten copies of my
book it really really really means a lot
to me so thank you guys again for
watching I believe in you I hope we
continue to believe in yourself and
whatever you're one where it is much
love I'll see you soon